this is a fox news alert we told you
that the national security agency has
been monitoring
this show and the content of tucker's
emails
according to a media outlet called the
record
the nsa has just completed its internal
review of the matter the nsa now admits
that it
unmasked tucker's identity after an
intelligence
intercept by law the identities of
american citizens are concealed when
they're caught up during foreign
intelligence gathering
they can only be unmasked in
extraordinary circumstances fox news has
just released
this statement quote for the nsa to
unmask tucker carlson or any journalist
attempting to secure a newsworthy
interview
is entirely unacceptable and raises
serious questions about their activities
as well as their original denial
which was wildly misleading we're always
glad
to see harmeet dillon when it comes
to issues like this harmeet what do you
make
of the nsa's revision of its story
well mark thanks for having me i'm not
buying it i think that
what they're saying now is inconsistent
with what they've said before and it's
also inconsistent with the facts as
tucker has revealed them
for example tucker said on his show on
several nights that
a source within the government came to
him and read
out several of tucker's texts and
messages
and so what the government is allegedly
saying today is that
the unmasking occurred regarding third
parties
talking with one another about tucker
carlson okay so that's inconsistent with
them intercepting tucker carlson's
number number two there's only a handful
of people in the united states
government who have the ability and the
right to unmask people and that right
was widely abused
during the end of the obama
administration 2016
and and and i'm afraid it's being abused
right now and so
this raises more questions than it
answers and i think that we really need
to be looking at reining in the abuses
in the national security community of
these types of issues and no
american journalists should be should be
surveilled this way and finally
these types of communications must never
be leaked to the media
axios had these communications so they
haven't answered that how did that
happen
and people totally unconnected with with
uh the act
so-called investigation unquote uh also
had them
as well and as you point out uh it looks
like we're back to uh the frenzy of
january 2017 on this unmasking nonsense
harmy i wanted to ask you about a
related story uh
nick clegg was once her britannic
majesty's deputy prime minister
uh now he's a senior executive at
facebook he recently
recently appeared on a podcast with an
ex
biden guy called andy slavitt and at one
point
slavitt prodded clegg to start censoring
this show
here's how nick clegg responded
and look on top of carlson you know
we've
you know i think he and his his team
don't like it but we've demoted and
labelled a
video that he's you know he and his team
have posted on the
the tucker carlson tonight facebook page
those i remember there was a
report about a teenager's adverse
reaction to the
to the vaccine and we demoted that and
labeled it we didn't remove it and
yeah and that gets us into a lot of hot
water you know because he's a he's a
very articulate
advocate for his his viewpoint and he's
got a lot of ardent supporters and they
kind of say oh you know
facebook shouldn't do that how dare you
you know how dave
culture takes action so you get it you i
mean we
you know look and that's i'm not
complaining about this at all i think
it's part of the the the consequences
and possibly the kind of
privilege of the success that that
facebook's had but
but we get it in the neck on both sides
harmony what's your reaction to this uh
so-called demoting
well that was that was very cringe to
listen to how awkwardly
uh clegg answered those questions and
the tradition of neville chamberlain you
know sort of
you know scurrying for for for favor uh
and that's that's a bit unfair to
neville actually
yeah i would say full retreat uh you
know but yes definitely the
definitely seeking accommodation with
the enemy if you will
which is typically the government is
typically you know something that
private companies want to stay away from
but the
successive administrations have put a
lot of pressure on social media
companies so naturally
they're very sensitive to pressure from
the government and where you have a
you have the administration biden uh
calling
mark zuckerberg a stone cold killer uh
you know
casually for not suppressing enough you
naturally have the circumstance where
these companies are going to feel a lot
of pressure to do it and they do and
we've had it not just only in this
vaccine setting
but also in the election law setting and
i've got a lawsuit pending against the
state of california
for censoring speech regarding the
election and taking down
people from twitter and and other
secretaries of state are doing this as
well so this is widespread we don't even
know the extent of it
it is dangerous and it is barred by the
first amendment and so i expect to see a
lot more litigation on this issue
let me ask you just sort of stepping
back since you brought up uh neville
chamberlain i mean the united kingdom is
a much diminished place
this day but uh still in normal
circumstances you would not think it
normal for a guy
to go from deputy prime minister to some
junior executive at facebook
as an any kind of promotion does that
fact alone
that zuckerberg is hiring deputy prime
ministers
tell us that facebook is now actually
bigger than most countries bigger than
most governments
oh it's been like that for a while and
what's concerning is not that it's
bigger than most
most countries but which countries are
the big markets that these social media
companies are seeking to
invade if you will they are very
interested in dominating the chinese
market in the indian market and
specifically
markets that don't have the respect for
free speech that even
the never neville chamberlain uk had and
so i think that this is a very dangerous
development
and they seem to acquiesce that of
course the government can tell us what
to censor and of course we're going to
do that
and please the government as much as
possible and you know in in
in so doing and falling over themselves
i think they're really putting
themselves at risk
of losing some of those protections from
liability
that these companies have won so one one
with so much lobbying
and and are very afraid of losing
yeah that's uh that's a very good point
uh and i i wish they would lose some of
those protections because there's no
good coming for any of us
in increasing the power of this guy
zuckerberg harmeet it's always great to
see you thank you so much
for joining us tonight hey sean hannity
here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else